[Music]
in Jr's world Gandalf is one of five
wizards sent by the Valar to guide the
inhabitants of middle-earth in their
struggles against the dark forces Sauron
Gandalf's body was mortal subject to the
physical rules of middle-earth but his
spirit was immortal as seen when he died
as Gandalf the Grey and resurrected as
Gandalf the White according to the
Wachowski script an awakened human only
has to link up and hack the neon binary
code of the matrix to learn how to fly a
helicopter in a matter of seconds or if
you are the one or one of the ones you
don't even need a helicopter you just
need a cool pair of shades Cheshire cats
can juggle their own heads ipads are
rudimentary no Quidditch match ends
until the Golden Snitch is caught and
the answer to the ultimate question of
life the universe and everything is most
certainly 42 just like real-life
fictional worlds operate consistently
within a spectrum of physical and
societal rules that's what makes these
intricate worlds believable
comprehensible and worth exploring in
real life the law of gravity holds seven
book sets of Harry Potter to millions of
bookshelves around the world we know
this to be true but we also know that
ever since JK typed the words wizard
wand and Wingardium Leviosa that law of
gravity has ceased to exist on the
trillions of pages resting between those
bookends authors of science fiction and
fantasy literally build worlds they make
rules Maps lineages languages cultures
universes alternate universes within
universes and from those worlds sprout
story after story after story when it's
done well readers can understand
fictional worlds and their rules just as
well as the characters that live in them
do and sometimes just as well or even
better than the reader understands the
world outside of the book but how how
can human made squiggles on a page
reflect lights into our eyes that send
signals to our brain
that we logically and emotionally decode
as complex narratives that move us to
fight cry sing and think that are strong
enough not only to hold up a world that
is completely invented by the author but
also to change the readers perspective
on the real world that resumes only when
the final squiggle is reached I'm not
sure anyone knows the answer to that
question yet fantastical fictional
worlds are created everyday in our minds
on computers even on napkins at the
restaurant down the street the truth is
your imagination and a willingness to
figuratively live in your own world are
all you need to get started writing a
novel I didn't dream up Hogwarts or the
Star Wars Cantina but I have written
some science thrillers for kids and
young adults here are some questions and
methods I've used to help build the
worlds in which those books take place I
start with a basic place in time whether
that's a fantasy world or a futuristic
setting in the real world it's important
to know where you are and whether you're
working in the past present or future
I'd like to create a timeline showing
how the world came to be what past
events have shaped the way it is now
then I brainstorm answers to questions
that draw out the details of my
fictional world what rules are in place
here this covers everything from laws of
gravity or not to the rules of society
and the punishments for individuals who
break them what kind of government does
this world have who has power and who
doesn't what do people believe in here
and what does this society value most
then it's time to think about day to day
life what's the weather like in this
world
where'd the inhabitants live and work
and go to school what do they eat and
how do they play how do they treat their
young and their old what relationships
do they have with the animals and plants
of the world and what do those animals
and plants look like what kind of
technology exists transportation
communication access to information
there's so much to think about so spend
some time living in those tasks
and the answers to those questions and
you're well on your way to building your
own fictional world once you know your
world as well as you hope your reader
will set your characters free in it and
see what happens and ask yourself how
does this world you created shape the
individuals who live in it and what kind
of conflict is likely to emerge answer
those questions and you have your story
good luck future world builder
[Music]
you
you